in today's fast changing Tech world big
companies like Google Amazon Microsoft
and Facebook are looking for people who
know about machine learning they want
these experts to use Ai and ml to create
new things Ai and ml can help us
understand a lot of information from
data and this is super important for
many fields like healthcare and finance
as Ai and ml became more and more
important
the need for people who understand them
is growing too these jobs are the future
because AI can make things better and
smarter like personalizing how we use
technology and making better choices in
this video we will be discussing the top
companies that are hiring for machine
learning Engineers so stay tuned and
watch till the end of this video but
before we begin let me ask you a quick
question so what is the primary goal of
machine learning a automating human
tasks B generating random data data C
creating complex algorithms or D
enhancing Hardware performance now you
can pause this video and answer in the
comment section below now let's start
with the first company that is hiring
for a machine learning engineer the
first company is Microsoft a Renown
multinational technology corporation
specializes in the creation of software
Hardware cloud-based services and
solutions pertaining to artificial
intelligence across diverse sectors and
Fields Microsoft is one of the leading
employers of machine learning Engineers
who are responsible for Designing
developing and deploying machine
learning systems and applications that
enhances the user experience and deliver
business value to become an ml engineer
at Microsoft one must have a solid grasp
of machine learning principles and
methodologies encompassing supervised
unsupervised reinforcement learning as
well as classification regression
clustering Etc a machine learning
engineer should possess the capability
to employ suitable machine machine
learning approaches to address diverse
scenarios machine learning Engineers
employed by Microsoft can make an
average annual total compensation of
$25,000 reflecting the company's
commitment to rewarding stop TI talent
in the field this way underscores
Microsoft recognition of the pivotal
role these professionals play in driving
Innovative a Solutions all right now
let's move to the next company that is
hiring for ML Engineers that is Apple
Apple's machine learning Engineers are
at the Forefront of innovation shaping
the company's commitment to privacy
focused Air Solutions these Engineers
work diligently to enhance series
capabilities optimize device performance
and develop groundbreaking applications
of machine learning across Apple's
ecosystem Apple's machine learning
engineer possess strong programming
skills expertise in various techniques
including deep learning tensor flow PS
and data manipulation proficiency they
excel in algorithm development
statistical analysis and Cloud
utilization ensuring innovative
solutions tailored to Industry domains
and effective collaboration with
interdisciplinary teams taking into
account supplementary bonuses and extra
compensation a machine learning engineer
employed at Apple can anticipate an
annual average total salary of
approximately
$212,000 this is a very good package if
we compare to other companies also if
you're interested in becoming an AI and
ml engineer then check our postgraduate
program in Ai and ml to elevate your
career prospects designed to understand
complex Concepts such as ml deep
learning NLP computer vision and
generative AI this certification equips
you with essential skills for success in
this Dynamic field led by industry
experts you will gain access to
Dedicated live sessions that delve into
the latest trends in AI including
generative modeling chat gbt and
explainable AI join us to expand your
knowledge enhance your expertise and
unlocking exciting possibilities in the
world of AI and ml engineering all right
now let's move on to the next company
that is hiring for ML engineer which is
Amazon an ml engineer at Amazon is a
professional who works on developing
deploying and maintaining machine
learning Solutions on the AWS Cloud
platform they can use AWS services and
tools to build train tune and deploy
machine learning models for various use
cases such as speech recognition
computer vision natural language
processing recommendation systems fraud
detections and more taking into account
the supplementary benefits and bonuses
an Amazon machine learning engineer can
earn an annual average salary of
$26,000 this salary package reflects the
company's commitment to valuing its
machine learning Talent all right now
let's move on to the next company that
is hiring for machine learning engineer
which is Accenture Accenture is another
another big tech company ml engineers at
Accenture is a specialist dedicated to
crafting implementing and developing
machine learning Solutions across
diverse Industries and client portfolios
with expertise in employing data
processing Technologies and Frameworks
like skit learn tlow and Pie torch an
Accenture AML engineer construct refines
trains and launches machine learning
models tailored for task spanning speech
recognition computer vision natural
language processing recommendation
system fraud detection and Beyond
exension ml engineer converts business
issues into Data REM Solutions architect
and manage ml tools analyze diverse data
and communicate insights they serve as a
data science experts influencing product
designs and presenting experiment
outcomes contributing to informed
business strategies and advanced
analytics when accounting for additional
bonuses and compensation machine
learning engineer working at denture can
look forward to earning an average total
pay of
$9,000 this comprehensive package
reflects the company's commitment to
recognize and rewarding the expertise of
its ml Genius Next on the list we have
is high radius ml engineers at high
radius works on developing deploying and
maintaining machine learning solution
for various clients and industries these
Engineers implo a range of data
processing Technologies and Frameworks
like skit learn tensorflow and py to
construct train optimize and Implement
machine learning models they work on
developing algorithms and models that
can be used to analyze large amounts of
data and extract insights from them they
also work on developing software tools
and libraries that can be used by other
Engineers to build machine learning
applications when the math includes
added incentives and supplementary perks
a machine learning engineer Journey with
high areas transforms into an equation
that sums up to an impressive salary of
$181,000 per anom so this was about high
radius all right now let's move on to
the next giant company that is Google an
ml engineered at Google undertakes the
task of creating constructing and
deploying machine learning models to
address business obstacles by leveraging
Google Cloud tools and deep
understanding of established machine
learning methods and strategies this
individual collaborates closely with
data scientists to transform their
findings into solutions that can be
expanded and trusted all while
maintaining a commitment to responsible
AI throughout the process a machine
learning engineer employed Google can
earn an average salary of
$230,000 additionally a Google ml
engineer can also receive cash bonuses
and stock options as a part of
compensation package next moving on to
IBM a machine learning engineer at IBM
is an expert who collaborates with
artificial intelligence and large scale
data to offer valuable business
perspectives and remedies as outlined by
IBM a machine learning engineer is
expected to possess the subsequent
proficiencies and duties vital expertise
in programming Lang languages such as
cc++ foundational Java and python
skillfulness in visualizing data and
Performing text analytics comprehensive
understanding of both business
intelligence and predictive modeling
drafting machine learning models
utilizing tools like water Studio caras
py torch and tensor flow Etc when
accounting for supplementary rewards and
extra intensives I repe and extra
incentives a machine learning engineer
at IBM can earn an average salary of 15
$1,000 so this was about IBM now let's
move on to the next company which is
Reddit an ml engineer at Reddit is
likely responsible for developing and
refining machine learning models that
enhance content recommendation systems
personalize user experience detect spam
and inappropriate content analyze user
behavior for insights and collaborate
with cross functional teams to ensure
the effective integration of these
models into the platform's backend
systems they work closely with data
science scientists software engineers
and product teams to analyze user
Behavior patterns derive meaningful
insights and optimize algorithms
indulging bonuses and supplementary
rewards an employee at Reddit that is
AML engineer at Reddit earns an average
salary of
$248,000 which is a huge salary when
compared to other companies so this was
about Reddit now let's move on to the
next company which is Facebook a machine
learning engineer at Facebook is
responsible for developing and
implementing machine learning models and
algorithms to enhance various aspects of
platforms such as content recommendation
user experience and AD targeting
contributing to the overall user
engagement and platform performance you
must have the capability to utilize
diverse data processing Technologies and
machine learning Frameworks like skit
learn tensorflow pytorch and among
others for the creation training and
optimization and deployment of machine
learning models these models scer to a
wider range of applications including
content suggestion enhancing user
interaction identifying spam
facilitating moderation enabling
personalization and Beyond within
confines of Facebook a machine learning
engineer earns an income of roughly
$26,000 this compensation Undercovers
the company's acknowledgement of the
pivotal role these professionals play in
driving technological innovation all
right now let's move on to our 10th
company that is sence the responsibility
of machine learning engineer at asss are
diverse and impactful they collaborate
with cross functional teams including
data scientists domain experts and
software Engineers to identify
opportunities where machine learning can
deliver value machine learning engineer
at Simons is well versed in data
pre-processing feature engineering and
model evaluation techniques they work on
optimizing models for performance
scalability and efficiency ensuring that
the developed Solutions can seamlessly
integrate with existing systems and
infrastructure this m involve utilizing
machine learning Frameworks and
libraries like tensor flow pie torch and
skit learn the compensation package for
machine learning engineer at Simons
amounts to
$126,000 annually so these were the 10
companies or we can say the top
companies that are hiring for ML
engineers in 2023 if you also want to
become an ml engineer then do check out
our course postgraduate program in Ai
and ml also listen to what a Learners
has to say about this
hey I'm sharar Jal I live in Ontario
Canada I have been in it sector for the
past 20 years I recently took the
professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning the course has changed the way
I look at things and help me back some
amazing freelance projects I started my
career in 1999 and over the years I have
worked with many companies my last terer
was with IBM Canada my aim was to
restart my career and learn something
that would help accelerate my
career I thought artificial intelligence
can make me Future Ready the course in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning is provided by simply learn in
association with Purdue University which
is why I chose the course I did not have
high expectations from online course
course but my experience was simply
awesome the quality of interaction
within the course was simply amazing the
course faculty was also very experienced
and knowledgeable after the course my
knowledge has grown manifold I have
immensely benefited from Python and
coding skills I am able to get some new
freelance projects also I am planning to
start an AI based startup with my friend
where I feel that the learning from the
course to be very helpful I am really
delighted and happy in my free time I
try to create meaningful content on
YouTube and I talk about new
technologies and what kind of courses
professionals should be taking along
with many other topics I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
com romise you should always learn from
the B all right guys with that we have
come to the end of this video If you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up I hope it really help you all thanks
for watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and of Skilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn n up and get certified click
here